- All right, Norman.
- Yes sir.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Glad to be back.
- [Mark] So where are we at today?
You started to work about a week ago.
- Yes.
Started work a week ago.
I'm a retail associate.
Got a nice little promotion
last night as a floor leader.
- You got a promotion?
- Yes.
- That's great.
- Yeah.
They just seen to leadership ability
and the knack for knowing
exactly what to do
how to do it, where to place things.
It's quite different
than what I'm used to.
I've never been a retail associate.
You know, a nice little
title but I'll take it.
And so it's a wonderful company.
Damn good benefits.
They got a lot of things in
there and I really enjoy it,
really, really enjoy it.
- [Mark] That's excellent.
So you're staying with your friend Don?
- Yes, my best buddy.
- [Mark] And how is that?
How was he, so Don uses?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you're using or not?
- No.
- You're not?
- [Mark] And like you mentioned before
Don kind of like goes somewhere else and -
- The degree of respectability
that he has for me and what I'm doing
and what I'm trying my best to do,
is it's an insurmountable.
I mean, he's a great person
and it doesn't bother me
that he does what he does.
You know, this is my friend.
Friend is a hell of a word.
You know you can have an associate
you can have a partner,
but he's my friend,
because when I really needed
some help, he was right there.
You know, no strings attached,
"Hey man this is what you need?
Come on."
And of course in my mind
I would like him to follow my path.
But in your own way,
you know it happens in different times.
I think I quoted a scripture once
before the Ecclesiastics 3:1
"A time and a purpose and
a season for everything."
You know, it's not his time,
maybe it's not the purpose.
It's not his season.
Maybe it's mine and made me by me
going through what I'm going through
to get where I wanna get,
will you know,
somehow pull him, you
know, he's his own man.
He's a grown man, you know?
And then decisions are
made by yourself, you know
power, choice and control.
You lose one, you lose them all.
That's just my own philosophy.
So it'll happen for him.
- Yeah.
- I know it will.
- [Mark] Have you wrapped
your head around the concept
that relapses are just
part of the process?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And there may be more.
- There may be more who knows
but I no longer suffer
from that impending doom.
I don't even count my days anymore.
When I go to work and I go home,
I rest, I wake up, when I wake up I say,
"Thank you for this day."
Because I don't wanna put
too much pressure on myself.
Not so much that I know myself.
I am beginning to know a little bit more
about the power and the
insidiousness of the disease.
Everything will be fine
not a cloud on the horizon,
(snaps finger) just like that.
A lot of people don't understand that.
And they say, "Why?"
Well if we could answer the question, why
then probably a lot of
people would be sober
and wouldn't do what they do.
And a lot of people wouldn't do
the other things that they
do beyond drugs and alcohol.
- [Mark] Yes and sometimes
its something stressful
but also sometimes it's something
positive will trigger it.
- Right.
- [Mark] Is it the inability to accept
the fortune that you just came across?
- Well no, you know what?
I really don't know.
I can't answer that question.
I had actually, you know
because I prided myself on
knowing a lot of things.
I actually went to my boss.
I think it was Tuesday night.
And I told him, I don't know.
And that was humbling for me
because usually Norman
knows, but I didn't know.
And it wasn't a point of me
being scared or something
like that of asking him.
But I thought to myself,
when I tried something three times,
I said, you know what, go to the boss.
- [Mark] This is something
pertaining to work?
- Yes and I just went.
- [Mark] I love somebody who
will tell me, I don't know
so much better than somebody
pretending like they do.
- And what they do, is
they say ask questions
and they'll always, they'll come around,
"Hey, Norman, are you all right?"
"Yeah, sure."
"Everything's fine?"
Then they'll audit you.
Now, I'm running around with a scanner,
but they can tap into my scanner
and find everything that I'm doing.
And at the end of the night,
they say who's made a mistake,
who put something wrong
and they look at the percentage as well.
I've done quite well.
I've scored a hundred percent every night
because I pride myself in doing my best.
And it's a new experience and learning.
So the newness really really motivates me
because it's something new
and I like to learn things.
So it's pretty cool.
I enjoy it.
And we're gonna take in one day at a time.
We're not looking forward
because there's some other things
that they told me last
night that could come down.
And I'm not looking at that.
No, stay right here.
Do what you have to do.
And just keep pushing.
Just take it a day at a time.
You don't have to look at
what's gonna happen in a month.
You don't have to think about
Just keep going.
Take it a day at a time.
Go to work, go on your break
go back to work, go to lunch, go to work
go on your break, go home,
rest, be ready for the next day.
- [Mark] And trying to break
a crack cocaine addiction
without rehab will be quite a feat, right?
- Well, I know a lot of
people who didn't go to rehab.
I know a lot of people who
went the religious route
I know a lot of people that
just stopped cold turkey.
It takes what it takes for a person.
You know, like I've said before,
I've been in 50 something rehabs.
And a lot of people had
commented on that too
on the page and you know,
some good and some bad.
And that was okay.
But you know, it's
really on the individual.
It doesn't matter where you go.
Okay a treatment facility
and we'll do one,
a couple of things.
It'll house you, that's one,
if you're homeless.
Two, it'll feed you.
Some have donated clothes
so it'll cloth you,
but why am I in that rehab?
Why did I go to treatment?
Did I really go to this
facility to seek treatment?
Or was it the fact that
everything got a real bad?
I robbed somebody,
I'm running from the law
and let me get in here
so I can get a paper
sign and go to the court.
And they say, Oh, you're in
rehab, everything's fine.
It's on the person.
What do you wanna do?
Do you really need treatment.
So there was some people that commented
on the page that said, "I needed to get
out of the Skid Row area
and go to treatment."
Well, guess what?
Skid Row is just not a place.
It's a mentality.
That's my own philosophy.
You can be living in Beverly Hills
with a Skid Row mentality.
You can be living in Playa Vista,
you can be living in these
wonderful communities
but you can have a Skid Row mentality.
So it's just not a place.
And guess what?
If I go to the treatment
center, who am I taking with me?
Me.
If I leave down from Skid Row
and go to another state who's taking me?
I'm still there.
So and for me, the kind of (indistinct)
and I wouldn't give a where it's at.
If I'm going to Alaska,
I'm going to ask Eskimo.
So it really doesn't matter where you go.
Do you have the wherewithal
to say within yourself
I'm tired of this.
I want something better.
Today, I do.
I don't know about tomorrow.
I don't know about the next day
but today right now as I'm speaking.
Yeah, I have the wherewithal
this is what I would like to do.
- [Mark] Excellent.
I wish you the best of luck.
Continue your forward progress.
- Thank you, sir.
Always a pleasure.
- [Mark] Do another
update in a week or two?
- Yes, sir.
- All right.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Thanks.
- Damn I kinda listened to
myself on that one (laughs).